[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see them what is
making the headlines with the consultant
editor of the daily mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kevin mcguire are with us from
now right through until near midnight
welcome to both of you say front pages
then let's start with the guardian and
the foreign secretary's grilling by mps
about the handling of the crisis in
afghanistan is on the front page with
dominic robb admitting the uk had been
caught out and surprised by the scale
and speed of the fall of kabul
daily telegraph details how coveted 19
booster jabs will be offered to the most
vulnerable experts are still
deliberating they say on whether they
should be offered to the wider
population and are waiting for more
evidence on the benefits of giving an
additional dose
that's also the lead for a story for the
daily mail which says ministers are
being urged to stop hanging around and
launch a mass booster jab program
the times goes with the booster jabs too
reporting the top-up vaccinations will
use fisa or moderna even for people who
have received the astrazeneca dose
previously
daily express reporting that protesters
are warning the health secretary sajid
javid that making millions of over 60s
pay for their prescriptions is a tax on
the sick
the financial times is leading with
plans for the uk to move its trident
submarine base from scotland in the
event of scottish independence
piers in the clear says the metro after
the regulator afghan found presenter
piers morgan was not in breach of the
broadcasting code over his controversial
comments about the duchess of sussex and
bran's attempts to silence him as a
chilling restriction on freedom of
expression
come to that in a moment but let's bring
in andrew pierce and kev mcguire and
start with the appearance before the
foreign affairs select committee of
dominic raab the guardian like a number
of newspapers picking up on what mr raab
said the central assessment was that
kabul would not fall this year but he
was shown a document in july his own
foreign office assessment which said
otherwise kevin
no absolutely warned
that it was possible the
taliban would
rise rapidly take power the uk embassy
would have to be closed and evacuated
and
this was before he went on his holiday a
date will not confirm but it's believed
to be in the 6th of august the document
was the 22nd of july and he has click
clearly has questions to answer on on
that the foreign foreign commonwealth
and development office his department
are trying to play down the report
a risk assessment uh analysis he was
taken by surprise with it when it was
produced by tom
tuganda the
chair of the foreign
affairs committee in the commons who
served twice in afghanistan as concerned
for instance his own interpreter is
stuck there with his family didn't get
airlifted out uh and he's been prove
he's proven a pretty effective foe of
the uh foreign secretary on this and
i thought they looked over those two
hours when he left um rob was overheard
to go
you know do a big few sound because he
got out but it was a pretty awful
performance i thought he doesn't seem to
know the numbers of people who are there
who still need to be airlifted uh out
and he he tried to create the impression
he was both um taken by surprised and
incredibly well prepared and expecting
it he can't have it both ways yes the
specific uh
paragraphs that tom tougenhart read out
he said your principal risk report dated
july the 22nd
said peace talks stalled u.s nato
withdrawal resulting in rapid taliban
advance this could lead to fall of
cities collapse of security forces as
taliban returned to power embassy may
need to close if security deteriorates
would you go on holiday if you just read
that andrew
no i wouldn't uh and i suspect from the
way it was it was definitely um dominic
rob's most uncomfortable moment during
that select committee hearing because he
actually said to tom toughenhart who was
chairing the committee what's the source
he didn't seem to realize that
touganhart was reading from a paper that
had been prepared for him as foreign
secretary now look millions of pieces of
paper across ministers desks all the
time but this was a very important
report a monthly report updating on the
situation in afghanistan and it revealed
that the taliban were already making
rapid advances across the country now if
he'd read that report
um i think it's inconceivable he would
have gone away
why didn't he read that report then well
then that's a failure in his office
isn't it because uh it's the job of his
civil servants his advisors to make sure
that the secretary of state sees the
most important stuff so it was difficult
tom toughener actually could have
exploited that more i think i mean
there's clearly no love lost between
these two guys they're both uh almost
the same age
two grants of backbencher rob's a
foreign secretary uh touganhart makes no
secret the fact he'd quite like to be a
foreign office minister but he could
have exploited it more and he didn't uh
and the other uncomfortable moment of
course for um
dominique iran was the repetition yet
again of the fact he simply doesn't know
how many people we've left behind in
afghanistan he said he thinks it's the
low hundreds how does he know it's not
the low thousands well tom tookenheart
of course what was he lieutenant colonel
in the ta served for four years in
afghanistan helped set up the government
of helmand province this is his brief
isn't it really but it would be blue on
blue if he continued to attack a
conservative foreign secretary of course
um the double page spread in the times
rob was warned of threat two weeks
before he went on holiday um if it was
uh the sixth of july august rather as
you said he did not um repeat when he
went on holiday and is that a central
question does it matter now does it
reveal questions about his competence
and why did he not say when he went on
holiday kevin
yeah presumably right the times believe
and they say it was the 6th of august it
finally came back on the 15th of august
after that extended weekend uh which is
now saying boris johnson allowed him to
it's it's because he he should he should
first of all probably not have gone and
certainly won't come back or should have
come back earlier and he won't say when
he went officially despite pretending
he's given a full account when he hasn't
because it was so early and he'd been
away so that would be nine nine days
before he before he came back
anybody watching the news reading
newspapers looking on the web listening
to radio would have seen the advance of
the taliban it seems the foreign
secretary although he claims he was
putting his family on the beach so he
could then be in the uh apartment to try
and handle a crisis he just it just
seems to have been asleep as uh as
general richard dannett the uh former
head of the uh the british army is
saying
he's getting so much flack
rob from his his colleagues and from
people in the in the military uh he's
very arrogant uh something like control
freak uh
officials the foreign officer said to be
very wary of him because he wants to do
everything himself well but he hasn't he
just clearly hasn't the the times in an
analysis concludes that it was very
bruising for him but there was no um
killer blow um i think that's right up
to a point but it's where does this memo
go because it's been played down by by
the foreign office just saying it was a
monthly assessment well whoever wrote
that should be promoted within in the uh
foreign office because they were well
ahead of the so-called intelligence
experts and more senior people who were
getting it wrong
uh quentin let's then in the times
article there their self-serving salvo
barely left a dent in him uh tom
tuggenheart was so keen to upstage
dominic robb with his pashtun expertise
it was a surprise he wasn't dressed in
the shalwa comes and natty little
topknot uh et cetera et cetera um but uh
dominic rob who's headed to the region
to which uh mr tugan had said a bit late
to make best friends i think isn't it um
suggested that now his strategy was safe
passage an international strategy around
counter-terrorism getting humanitarian
relief much needed to the area and
regional stability he's trying to move
on from the last few weeks of what we've
seen in the chaotic scenes in kabul can
he just can he move on has he done
enough andrew just very quickly i'm
sorry i'm not sure he can because look
we still don't know why he didn't make
that telephone call which he was asked
to make while he was on holiday in crete
in his luxury hotel i don't regret
ministers having holidays they work very
hard but not enough money in my view and
he's entitled holiday but he didn't make
that phone call to the pakistan foreign
minister uh he delegated to a junior
minister
and that call was was never made now
that was crucial because that was all to
do with evacuations if you'd spoken to
the pakistan foreign minister he could
have probably told the foreign secretary
there's a real problem here you're gonna
have to start getting your people out
right now immediately no time to waste
because he would have known being so
much closer on the ground how far and
quickly the taliban was advancing so
that still needs to be resolved um but
you're right he is trying to move on and
i think the times
assessment is right there wasn't a
killer blow but you know normally there
never is with these mps because if an mp
is developing quite a good line of
questioning they only get so many
minutes and then it's on to the next one
and they're more interested in asking
their questions then uh and
grandstanding there's too much of that
goes on at these select committees yes
it was ever thus i fear um but certainly
there were some pre-prepared answers
from mr rob from mid-march to the 30th
of august i had over 40 meetings or
telephone calls where afghanistan was on
the agenda and he listed all the other
nations he has to worry about from you
know somalia to hong kong to belarus and
so on but on the front page of the daily
telegraph there we see the result the
spoils of war once again
all these helicopters which everyone
suggested could not be flown that were
left behind and there are taliban
fighters flying a captured black hawk
helicopter bearing their flag during
what they called a victory rally in
kandahar kevin
yeah they've got to be anna the best
equipped militant force in history
because they have inherited so much u.s
military equipment that was left for the
afghan army now
maybe the pilot uh was in the afghan
army air force and has defected and
joined the the taliban or maybe the
taliban weren't the
country boys that was the description of
nick carter the uh the head of the
british armed forces
and they are rather more sophisticated
than they were given credit for but it's
incredible the u.s somehow didn't at the
very least
disable those uh helicopters by somehow
taking out circuits and wrecking the
electronics so they couldn't be they
could that couldn't be flown i would
have thought uh countries around the
world who are uh enemies and rivals of
the uh of the us whether it's china uh
russia or wherever will be heading to
afghanistan to buy equipment at the very
least to be able to study it and get any
developments they can to produce their
own it's
it's an astonishing treasure trove of
military equipment that's been left for
the taliban
let's move on shall we to gone then gone
then i'm just going to say i think the
fact that america that the fact america
has left all this
uh arms and munitions behind is a sign
that they were completely caught on the
hot too it's not just british
intelligence failed here there's a
collective failure by the g7 you didn't
seem to realize how close the taliban
were to uh car ball and that's why the
americans have left so much military
hardware there uh and and the afghan
army of course disintegrated within a
matter of days yeah rather reinforces
dominick robb's uh central argument
about the central assessment does it not
anyway um daily mail your paper then
andrew just quickly if you don't mind
now give britain a booster it needs this
is after the half million vulnerable
those on immunosuppressant drugs or with
blood cancer and so on are told they
will get a booster or rather a third
vaccine
yeah what we're saying is can we please
get on with it because the joint
committee on vaccinizations
immunizations are taking their time big
time they still haven't told us whether
uh children from 12 to 16 should be
jabbed in schools and we don't know yet
whether we're going to get this booster
now i'd have thought it was obvious
people over a certain age i include
kevin and i in that category i'm afraid
kevin much more than meeks he's much
older we will need boosters but i'm
thinking particularly people in their
80s and 90s they should we should have
that booster i would have thought
at the same time that school children
get their jabs if that's going to be the
advice of the jcvi because we've got the
capacity for it we've got the drugs for
it and i think they've got the know-how
how to do it but what they've got to do
is pull their finger out what are they
waiting for
oh it's frozen
why why are they taking so long get on
with it okay let's see if they're
listening uh awaiting all of those
announcements obviously no i've got time
i've got time because i know you want to
talk about piers morgan who's also on
the front page of the daily mail and the
store in the ft uh two uh uk drawing up
plans to shift the trident submarines
abroad if scotland secedes back in just
a moment with all of that
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now the consultant
editor of the daily mail andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kev maguire um i know you worked
with him maybe you win again who knows
uh piers morgan uh in the clear he says
uh andrew you're already starting to
chuckle that worries me carry on yeah
well kevin and i were on the program the
morning he had the famous uh meltdown
over meghan markle but this is a really
really important ruling by ofcom
broadcast regulator they've said uh if
piers morgan was to be censored for
giving an opinion uh uh even if it's an
opinion that might cause offence that is
a chilling threat chilling was the word
they used the free speech and it's and
they also made the point in their in
their judgment that piers morgan was
very outspoken he is outspoken about
meghan markle he thinks she's ghastly so
do i by the way uh and uh but he said
that the off-camera what made clear he
was challenged in the studio by susanna
reid as co-presenter and uh the weather
guy alex beresford so it wasn't as if it
was just one view being put forward but
they defended the right of him to have
that to express those views as strongly
as he likes and it's interesting that
even adam bolton your colleague
anna has just said this is a very
important moment bill neely used to work
for itn who's won a bafta hugely
important this is a pillar of our
british establishment free speech so i'm
really pleased he's won and i hope
she'll think twice now before she tries
to get people sacked from presenting tv
programs if she doesn't like the cut of
their cloth but but if the interview was
all about very personal moments for her
about how she had felt uh you know like
taking her own life that being in the
royal family was so you know it's raw
moments in her life then actually having
having a sort of a journalist on a set
showboating about it uh was something
that had made her upset is she not
allowed to complain about it
yeah of course you can complain about it
but but but the fact is why should why
is a journalist in britain or any other
uh democracy for that matter not allowed
to express a view as to whether they
believe what the the guest is saying in
an interview it wasn't an interview so
much as uh just a broadcast i mean oprah
winfrey didn't challenge her about
anything it was a shameful way to
conduct an interview so why can't piers
morgan express a view as to whether he
believes her or not i didn't believe a
lot of what she said either i made no
view as to whether she felt suicidal i'm
very sorry if she did but i still find
it astonishing that she couldn't find
anybody to help her with her mental
illness problems when her husband is
patron of two major mental health
charities
anna piers morgan did initially question
whether she felt suicidal then backed
off on that
he realized he'd overstepped a mark i
thought the judgment was very
was finally balanced because it talked
about his comments being potentially
harmful and
and offensive and itv should be more
careful on how mental health is
discussed in future but as andrew said
because susanna reid alex beret and also
chris ship the
royal correspondent all challenged piers
morgan so it was more balanced in the
studio that's why the free speech could
have been defended if susanna reid alex
beresford
and chris ship hadn't been around that
morning uh in part the discussion it
might have gone another way against
piers more i might say it would but it
might it might have done that and it's
rather like you know we discuss on the
press preview with you and andrew is
usually wrong and outrageous about stuff
and i'm wise and right and if ballot
balancers out
and we save it we save it all
about anything my wisdom and insights
and
fairness as against his uh
lack of
okay you you save us do you by your ex
what do you think of meghan mark or
kevin
oh my god
can i go quickly to the ft
um very quickly to the ft we're running
out of programme uh the uk making plans
thinking ahead of uh ahead of itself
it's a rare moment i suppose
well this is a story that comes up every
time that there's thought to be possibly
a referendum on independence in scotland
the the fazley nuclear base
what happens if scotland goes
independent the ft is saying the
government has been giving serious
thought to it one option you lease you
can you lease the land of the newly
independent scottish government or what
they think might be more realistic
moving the base to the united states
cheaper no capital investment but that
would suggest that our independent
nuclear deterrent is a lot less
independent if it's in american waters
okay andrew's not kevin well
not independent it couldn't be used
without you as permission france has
also considered the snp uh being
anti-nuclear and is a politic
our support would save 200 billion kevin
and andrew
morrow continued that debate without me
weren't they we'll see you in a moment
thank you no no